pennsylvania gop senate front runner dr
mehmet oz is with us uh
i certainly would want to be in your
position um
a very close race we knew going in this
would be a tight race but the most
amazing observation i have about this if
you look at the three top leaders and
you look at the the percentages of vote
all three ran as donald trump make
america great again conservatives all
three of you
now you happen to get the president's
endorsement which uh obviously paid
dividends for you but
um what does that say about where the
part where the people in pennsylvania
are i think it's very telling
now the people are very supportive of
president trump and the more joe biden's
in office the more they remember those
halcyon days of the trump administration
but if i can comment on this race you
know we have covered all counties to
ensure that the ballots correctly
counted this election is ours we have
done well what i want to do today though
is is to talk about unifying our party
because those three front runners and
their other candidates as well all work
their tails off but we need to unite to
take on fetterman you mentioned earlier
and i am praying that he makes a full
recovery as a heart doctor trained at
the university of pennsylvania i am
optimistic
but this really comes down to what
people in pennsylvania want people in
pennsylvania have a clear choice
fetterman is to the left of joe biden
he's not equal dividends to the left so
he supports spending he supports
restricting energy production which in
our commonwealth is a big issue that
drives inflation number one driver of
inflation i want to liberate energy
producers to reduce inflation democrats
when open borders is a real hot topic
here i want to shut down the cartel run
human trafficking operation at the
border and also shut down the drugs
they're bringing in that makes them even
more money betterment wants socialized
medicine like bernie sanders we saw and
what happens when you have one size fits
all approaches that didn't work during
covert it doesn't work in general i want
private solutions customized to your
needs i'm a doctor i spent my life
studying this i will take these messages
to every corner of the commonwealth i
pledge that including places republicans
sean don't often go you know i've got
the pittsburgh and philly to do free
clinics we've taken care of thousands of
folks so i understand the challenges of
working with people who feel forgotten
and i got to say you know this about me
because the hardest part of this
campaign in many ways is getting you to
vet me
that i have my core conservative values
but there's a lot of love in my heart
for folks on the other side of the aisle
and we will pull this commonwealth
together as i campaign into the fall i
said it and i meant that i didn't
endorse you because we're friends and we
are friends i i
i wanted to know that you were america
first i wanted to know you would fight
hard as a conservative uh a make america
great again conservative a trump
conservative a save america conservative
at this point you know i think again you
just look at this you got fully 87
of the vote in the primary and
pennsylvania republicans are all
claiming the maga mantle that is a
profound number um but uh dr oz we'll uh
we'll watch it was we heard matt's
analysis we got yours i did a lot of
digging myself uh i'm pretty confident
my numbers but time will tell we really
appreciate you being with us and coming
on as often as you did thank you